welcome to the finale of my first love
park board that's right [ __ ] y'all
been cursing at me because I'll do all
these cliffhangers a [ __ ] huh somebody
told me to go into drastic huh that so
last week if you guys remember I said I
finally confessed to her how I felt
about this whole situation about me and
her and we decided to talk about it
face-to-face at her place but it also
here is this to be honest with you
when I was walking to her house and I
got to the front I was nervous as hell
it's kind of funny because right before
I walked into her house I was pacing
back and forth trying to get myself all
psyched up like remember you would care
that you wanted to psych yourself up you
will walk around your room and tell
yourself your dick was huge right
no just me I'll do that even just
kidding y'all nasty April Fool's it's
November
Oh so when I finally got enough courage
to walk up to the front of her house I
remember I was so scared that my hand
was just hovering right in front of the
door I look like the first Asian dude
advocating black power and [ __ ] look
even though I said I wasn't sure what to
expect let's be real she was gonna break
my itty-bitty great heart and I wasn't
sure if I was ready to hear what she had
to say because if she told me to move on
there was no maybe there was no
possibility of a chance of us getting
together and I wasn't sure if I was
ready for that because I genuinely
believed if it wasn't her there wasn't
anybody else so after I finally knock at
the door as she opened and I expected
her to have the saddest face on earth
and she was gonna tell me I was born
with a vagina but to my surprise she was
actually smiling so when she told me to
come inside her house I sensed that
something was off like something felt
genuinely different now remember I told
you that I was scared shitless of her
dad so you have to realize that me
walking into her home was like walking
into a haunted house Aeons would you my
butthole was clenched so tight I could
have cracked a walnut with that [ __ ] mmm
you see prior to that day the furthest I
ever got into her house was at the front
door so you know if I want to need
further her father what a Jackie Chan
the [ __ ] out of my upper lip but even
though my guard was up there was a
specific moment that day that I will
remember for the rest of my life
when she was showing me around her house
I stopped right behind her and as she
was showing me this painting she stopped
and she leaned back into me now you have
to understand something this is a very
important moment because up until this
point in our friendship she never did
anything like this I got high fives
hugs maybe a pat on the back but other
than that this never happened you know
when this happened a part of me was
thinking what the hell is going on but
the other part of me was thinking please
don't get a boner ladies if you don't
know this by now there is always a 50%
chance that a teenage boy will pop a
boner out of nowhere but in all
seriousness the first time she ever
leaned into me that moment was
unforgettable
because for me for the past four years I
always wanted to be that guy and even as
much as I did I never thought it would
happen and when it finally did I wasn't
sure what was going on so after she got
done showing me the art in her living
room we went upstairs to go check out
her room and up to this point her room
was the Greek mythology that [ __ ] did
not exist so as we continue conversing
in a room I sat down on her bed and as a
conversation continued on she eventually
laid her head on my lap and I gotta tell
you something that that moment right
there felt perfect but you see it wasn't
just her physical mannerisms that
changed around me it was also the way
that she spoke to me I can't really
describe how the tone of her voice
changed but her voice just had this
different texture warmth to it that
wasn't there before when she spoke to me
as much as I couldn't believe what was
going on something was gonna happen that
was gonna change the course of our
friendship forever and I really didn't
expect that this was going to happen
we got butt-naked that's what I said no
no we did it yeah filthy McNasty I know
what you're thinking if you guys didn't
know I sang a lot in high school and at
that time I actually had aspirations of
becoming a musician but she and I
actually used to sing to each other on a
regular basis so while she was resting
her head on my lap I decided to sing her
a song as we were singing the song to
each other she decided to go ahead and
change the lyrics a little bit she
replaced the word miss with the word
like she's saying
I like you haha and as corny as that
sounds
was she saying that word I had to do a
double-take and before we even go any
further I want you guys to realize what
that very moment was like after four
years of always being that guy on the
other side she finally acknowledged me
the way that I've been seeing her and I
got to tell you that moment was
indescribable until this very day I
truly believe that emotion that I felt
that day is how you should feel about
the person that you're with anyways
before I left her house I remember I
really wanted to kiss her but I don't
want to seem like a creeper or kind of
rush things too fast so I just kissed
her on the forehead and I and I left
that day and plus if I kissed her at
that moment yeah I probably would've
popped a boner I don't look for me it
has always been quality over quantity
and waiting this long for the right
person to say yes was worth it because
how differently when that moment have
felt if I gave up and moved on somebody
else and although people may not agree
she was worth every second of heartache
to finally be able to say that I was in
a relationship with the girl who was my
very first love you know funny enough
when this happened I actually told all
my close friends what happened but for
some reason I forgot to tell my best
friend nagamma that jackass was last I
felt until this day he still hold that
[ __ ] against me that's right I hope you
watching this fool I forgot get over it
I'd let you tell me everything you
judging me hmm but I was 17 or 18 then
and if you guys are wondering what
happened to us and if we're still
together
um that's a story for another time you
know as I got older I started to learn
something that even though people
experienced the same situation it
doesn't mean that we all saw the same
thing similarly so let me ask you guys
something
how do you remember your first love well
YouTube what's going on so my first love
is now done so there are other stories
to this that will continue and I hope
you guys like this series I mean it was
a truthful story from my perspective um
and it was it was it was an interesting
journey of writing this all out for you
but I hope you guys enjoyed it and if
you haven't seen the first three parts
go to check it out to my
right and I'll see y'all next week peace
out BAM go for broke apparel cop yo [ __ ]
because we're almost out that's right I
said we're almost out what's up what's
up no yeah yeah yeah